[Musica]
il mio nome e alessia ciarrocchi e di
professione cerco risposte perché sono
uno scienziato e mi occupo di ricerca
scientifica
le domande alle quali cerco di
rispondere attraverso nel nostro vissuto
quotidiano
ma si declinano nell'infinitamente
piccolo perché il mio settore di
specialità e la biologia molecolare che
come obiettivo si pone quello di
spiegare la vita in termini di relazioni
e interazioni fra molecole nelle
dinamiche molecolari che mantengono una
cellula e che quindi su più vasta scala
mantengono il nostro organismo e
l'intero sistema animale e vegetale così
come lo sperimentiamo tutti i giorni si
realizza l'equilibrio
immaginate spazi infinitamente piccoli
all'interno dei quali si concentrano
quantità infinita mente grandi di
singole entità
ciascuna di queste entità fa cose e lo
fa in maniera autonoma e altamente
specializzata ma in perfetta armonia e
sincronia con l'intero sistema perché se
la sincronia non è perfetta
il sistema non funziona questa entità
che lavorano a ciclo continuo e in spazi
sovraffollati sono le molecole e l'esito
del loro operato e la vita in tutte le
forme in cui noi la conosciamo bene noi
biologi molecolari insieme ai nostri
colleghi biochimici biofisici
bioinformatici passiamo le nostre
giornate cercando di decifrare quella
complessa serie di relazioni allo scopo
di spiegare la vita ma soprattutto allo
scopo di capire le basi e i fondamenti
di molte delle malattie che affliggono
l'uomo se da un lato questa complessità
è estremamente affascinante ed essendo
così dinamica ci permette di continuare
a porci delle domande e quindi ci
permette di continuare a sviluppare
progetti di ricerca
dall'altra questa complessità è talmente
profonda da determinare in maniera
automatica la consapevolezza che molto
probabilmente non arriveremo mai a
decifrarla completamente e che quindi
nonostante gli sforzi della ricerca
scientifica l'uomo è destinato a
rimanere
in parte nell'ignoranza ora la
consapevolezza della falla città del
proprio lavoro insieme all'entità degli
sforzi e dell'impegno che ciascun
ricercatore mette nella propria attività
quotidianamente determina in maniera
abbastanza spontanea un certo senso di
frustrazione che consapevolmente o
inconsapevolmente ciascuno di noi
operatori del settore porta nel proprio
bagaglio di vita
ora mai forse come negli ultimi tempi
abbiamo parlato e sentito parlare di
scienza e di ricerca scientifica perché
la scienza e la ricerca scientifica sono
amate o odiate dall'opinione pubblica a
seconda dei punti di vista e delle
convenienze pertanto se in tempi di pace
e di prosperità la scienza e la ricerca
scientifica sono spesso quelle delle
lobby dei vaccini e dei farmaci in tempi
di emergenza e difficoltà come quelli
che abbiamo vissuto e che stiamo ancora
vivendo intorno alla scienza e alla
ricerca scientifica si radunano le
persone come unica e ultima speranza
dell'intera umanità ora questa
percezione ondivaga del valore del
nostro lavoro non fa altro che aggravare
quel senso di frustrazione verso il
quale abbiamo detto noi scienziati siamo
spontaneamente predisposti definendo uno
stato che in maniera elementare potremmo
chiamare la sindrome dell'incompreso e
quindi nel corso di questo decennio per
la prima volta dall età dei lumi la
comunità scientifica si apposta nei
confronti dell'opinione pubblica con un
quesito insolito e per niente scontato
la scienza e democratica
molti dei miei colleghi pensano di no
pensano che la scienza non sia
democratica perché la scienza che si
basa sui fatti e se lui e sulle evidenze
non può lasciare alcuno spazio
all'opinione dei singoli e soprattutto
perché per fare è parlare di scienza uno
deve essere formato a farlo in questa
accezione però la scienza e la ricerca
scientifica solo di pochi
fatta da pochi e viene di fatto offerta
alla società civile come se fosse una
specie di regalo
io personalmente che il mio lavoro lo
vivo non penso per niente che la ricerca
e la scienza siano valori non
democratici anzi penso fortemente che la
ricerca scientifica e la scienza siano
dei valori molto democratici per una
serie di buoni motivi
primo la scienza e la ricerca
scientifica sono per tutti e di tutti
la scienza opera sempre per tutte le
persone a prescindere da qualsiasi
diversità di attitudine classe sesso
razza pensiero politico e religione
articolo 3 della costituzione italiana e
i risultati della scienza sono sempre
messi a disposizione dell'intera
comunità
2 la scienza è trasparente e quindi
sottoposta sempre al giudizio di terzi
sa che un risultato che viene generato
nei nostri laboratori possa essere
riconosciuto universalmente valido è
necessario che questo risultato venga
sottoposta alla valutazione della
comunità scientifica quindi venga reso
pubblico e valutato e valutato dagli
altri scienziati non solo ciascun
passaggio del complesso percorso con cui
il risultato scientifico viene generato
deve essere reso pubblico è sottoposto
alla comunità scientifica per essere
validato ciascun progetto di ricerca
ciascun lavoro scientifico prima di
essere rilasciato
viene valutato da commissione di pari
questo da un lato garantisce il rigore
della scienza ma dall'altro tutela
enormemente l'onestà intellettuale di
chi la scienza la opera 3 la scienza è
pluralista
nessun ricercatore lavora da solo
ciascuno di noi lavora in gruppi
all'interno dei quali al raggiungimento
di uno stesso obiettivo
collaborano si confrontano e si
scontrano opinioni di vista formazioni
attitudini e capacità differenti da un
lato questa pluralità che è il
fondamento di ciascun valore democratico
garantisce un avanzamento più rapido
dell'attività di ricerca ma dall'altro
tutela la correttezza del sis
tema 4 la scienza è condivisa ciascun
risultato scientifico viene pubblicato
quindi messo a disposizione dell'intera
comunità scientifica non solo qualsiasi
strumento tecnologia applicazione noi
realizziamo nel corso di un progetto
scientifico viene messo anch'esso a
disposizione del resto della comunità
scientifica per fare in modo che altri
gruppi di ricerca possano avvalersene e
quindi andare più veloci nel loro lavoro
la condivisione dentro la scienza sta
raggiungendo in questi ultimi tempi
livelli di un'importanza fondamentale
nell'ultimo decennio grazie ad una
rivoluzione tecnologica abbiamo avuto
accesso a tecnologie che ci permettono
di realizzare profili genetico
molecolari estremamente approfonditi su
ciascun individuo
l'applicazione di queste tecnologie
nell'intero globo sta definendo una
quantità di informazioni dal punto di
vista genetico molecolari di tantissimi
stati patologici
pensate solo a cosa abbiamo imparato
sulla genetica di tumore nel corso degli
ultimi anni
ora a prescindere da quale sia
l'istituto all'interno del quale
ricercatore opera a prescindere da quale
sia il paese in cui questi dati vengono
generati siamo obbligati a riversare
questa informazione in repositori comuni
sul web accessibili gratuitamente a
tutta la comunità scientifica definendo
di fatto una risorsa incredibile per
l'avanzamento della conoscenza
scientifica a 360 gradi ma soprattutto
realizzando l'unico esempio riuscito di
globalizzazione e superamento dei
confini nazionali
5 la scienza è progressista perché
lavora sempre sull'idea di un domani che
sia migliore di oggi
bene per tutti questi motivi io quindi
credo che la scienza e la ricerca
scientifica siano valori profondamente
democratici ma che la scienza e la
ricerca scientifica possano continuare
ad essere democratici è necessario che
la scienza e la ricerca scientifica
continuino ad essere liberi perché la
scienza
segue la strada che è detta
dalle domande da cui nasce e dai
risultati che via via vengono generati e
all'interno di questo percorso non ci
possono essere condizionamenti di
concetto così come non ci possono essere
condizionamenti economici e logiche di
profitto
quindi affinché la scienza e la ricerca
possano continuare ad essere liberi e
quindi continuare ad incarnare un valore
democratico è fondamentale che la
scienza e la ricerca scientifica siano
pubbliche perché la scienza così come la
giustizia l'istruzione e l'ambiente sono
beni della comunità e come tali da tutta
la comunità devono essere sostenuti e
come si sostiene la ricerca pubblica si
investe sulla professionalità e sulla
competenza di chi la ricerca la opera
perché non c'è scienza senza gli
scienziati chiudo con un concetto che mi
è particolarmente chiaro caro
molto spesso quando si parla di
finanziamenti alla ricerca si insiste
sul concetto di ricerca utile intendendo
come tale un tipo di ricerca che esiti
in un prodotto il più velocemente
possibile lasciatevelo dire gran parte
del nostro lavoro non esiterà mai in un
brevetto la maggior parte del nostro
lavoro non arriverà a spostare
minimamente la vita pratica delle
persone però con il nostro lavoro tutti
i giorni noi concorriamo ad aggiungere
evidenze noi concordiamo ad aggiungere
un tassello in più nel quadro complesso
della conoscenza di fatto operando per
il progresso globale dell'intera umanità
dai tempi della pietra la ricerca è
stato lo strumento che ha acceso la luce
della conoscenza e la conoscenza è
l'unico strumento che l'uomo per
superare i propri limiti e vincere le
proprie paure
[Applauso]